richard sherman placed on injured
reserve yesterday he's got a calf injury
and one of the things we need to
remember about injury reserve this year
because in the past not that long ago if
you're put on injury reserve you're done
then they opened the door for a couple
of guys to go on ir for eight weeks in
return and this year it was going to be
three guys could go on ir for eight
weeks in return and then came the
pandemic and they decided it's open
season anyone can be put on ninja
reserve and they can come back after
three weeks so it's not nearly the doom
and gloom
that it was once upon a time but the
thing is it's so open-ended you don't
know when a guy's coming back and you
know the ultimate bill belichick
approach to things like this is you put
the guy in ninja preserving you never
talk about him again until he comes back
he may be gone for the rest of the
season he may be gone for three weeks he
may be gone for three months we don't
know yeah but with sherman kyle talked
about it yesterday it sounds like he's
not going to be out for very long but we
know at a minimum he's got to miss three
weeks yeah well it's it's a big blow
regardless you know this is a team that
had a little issue stopping the pass
game just this past week we saw that and
i would sit here and argue too that
cornerback play is not one of the
strengths of the 49ers to begin with
it's not you know they are helped out in
a big way by the fact that they have the
best pass rushing front four there is
you know we saw last week that when kyla
murray he can buy some time and stuff
the 49ers are not a man-to-man lockdown
cover type team
so it is a it does stink for them as far
as that's concerned you know they're
still trying to figure out who they want
the other guy to be as far as on the
other side of richard sherman he's
healthy there was a lot of competition
there you know a kill with a spoon he's
a little banged up does jason ver ver uh
verit uh jason verret sorry
can he come up and be healthy he's a guy
that had great potential early in his
career but all he's done has been
injured ever since then
so
yeah sherman's smart he understands the
scheme he gets the secondary on the
right page he's a leader and they're
going through a little adversity right
now and it won't help their team with
him not being there this is the kind of
guy you want in the locker room in these
kind of scenarios right now when you're
owen one coming off a super bowl loss
he's been in this chair before and knows
what it's all about and he could be wise
and help out the rest of the football
team
and costly for richard sherman in a
different way he's got a base salary
this year of eight million dollars but
he's got a million tied up in
participating in 90 of the defensive
snaps that goes out the window now with
missing three games he's got a million
tied up in making it to the pro bowl
that's going to be a tougher thing to do
when you miss it at least three games
and he's got two million tied up in
being first or second team all pro
that becomes a lot harder to do when you
miss at least three games plus 62 500
that goes out the window and per game
roster bonuses so he's looking at at
least 4 million as a practical matter 4
million
4.18 million to do the math almost
accurately that is going to go away
because of this most likely although
it's not a done deal that he can't make
the pro bowl or make first or second
team all pro it's just gonna be really
hard if he misses three games and uh
look i
there are mixed opinions on whether or
not he should be paid like a top ten
corner do you view him right now as a
top ten coin i do not i do not i think
he's a great fit for this scheme and
because of their front four that fools
people a little into thinking that he's
a top ten corner that way but no
again i'm always gonna put top ten
corners in a little bit of the category
of like can you live on an island you
know we're not paying you
15 million dollars a year to like just
pedal back and coach sit the coach said
sit in the zone coverage and read things
out no the really good ones are matching
up against the number one receivers the
number two receivers sherman's good
still don't get me wrong but he's
limited in his ability to play
one-on-one he just understands the
scheme he's smart he doesn't get up a
lot of big plays and then the other
thing that he's very valuable with
because he's very comfortable in the
scheme is you know he'll take a chance
every now and then because he
understands what teams are trying to do
to attack that scheme and he can kind of
see plays unfold that way and then maybe
jump around that he's not supposed to
jump or do something like that but no do
i think he's in the class of you know
the gilmores the ramses the xavien
howards and byron jones and all those
guys absolutely not
and you know it's fitting then he's
number 11 at 8 million dollars in base
salary last year i think he did benefit
from that pass rush right and the name
recognition to get to the pro bowl to
make it to second team all-pro and to
unlock significant money via incentives
that if you put him on any other team
last year maybe he wouldn't have seen
but the bottom line is they need him
back they have too many guys banged up
in the secondary but if the pass rush is
is as potent as it was last year
chris you or i could be playing
defensive back well it wouldn't matter
if the quarterback can't get the ball
out of his hands before he gets blown up
by nick boson well
i mean you're right about i don't know
if we could play or not you know because
then teams would just throw screens and
then they'd go okay
or sims tackle like this receiver and we
probably wouldn't so it wouldn't help
out either uh but but it but it does
help out their secondary there's no
doubt about that it's it's what's
special about their football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports